hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
John's my name we are gonna do the task
that when you set out on this mission
you are guaranteed a hundred percent
like ratio what our YouTube guaranteed
to succeed never divisive people always
go hey those are just their opinions on
our YouTube video but I have my opinions
and I'm okay to each their own
these lists they're all subjective I
love that that's how everyone usually
responds especially with hardcore
fandoms yeah totally people who have you
know spent years of their lives
dedicated to these characters are always
people who thanks guys for being so
sweet really do appreciate that where
you're gonna rank the 22 MCU films
this wasn't a daunting task no really
easy it came out in like five minutes
John hi we did not sit down together
look at the list and spend close to an
hour going mmm which would alright so
seriously we did think each one of these
numbers through yes yes we wanted to
make sure that we were honest with
ourselves and that we were you know not
trying to you know satisfy anyone's
opinions yeah we just wanted to make
sure we were and we thought every one of
these through because if the thing is we
did this based off of not doing a giant
re-watch and then you know deciding
which number goes where we did this as
based off which one left the biggest
impact on us you know like they're some
of these movies we haven't seen since
they've come out or you know it's been a
while since just some of them so going
through we're like which one really
stuck with us and that's how we sort of
organize this on the the emotional
impact each one of these sort of left us
with because I feel like when I look at
this list I wouldn't rank any of these
below a you know there's a good number
out of 10 I wouldn't put any of them
below a 5 for me personally I
I wouldn't I might dip into a
four-for-one or two of them but yeah for
the most part Marvel has never made a
movie that I have just flat-out hated or
thought was like bad yeah like even the
the least of them have some elements I
appreciate yeah exactly so kicking off
this list number 22 mmm funny enough
this was the movie I was like should we
move it because this is the go to movies
is the answer people are like Marvel
films I mean Captain Marvel is a little
bit debatable but with some circles but
for Verena this this one is for the
longest time the bad one and that number
22 Thor the dark world you see Thor the
dark world I actually have a lot of
elements about this movie that I do
appreciate you know III think a lot of
the action in it is very cool I like
that they were going for for sure
Thor Loki was cool I thought the designs
were great like there's so much to
appreciate about the movie that for me
when it's being exciting it or intending
to be exciting I find it exciting the
thing though is I I do not remember most
of it and not because oh it's been a
long time it's just a lot doesn't really
stick with you it's kind of a movie that
at times even though there are exciting
elements it is sort of even rather black
yeah or a little bit of a slugfest sort
of sit through or sometimes though the
writing is a little bit annoying so
while I think there's a lot of actually
more pros than what most people probably
give the movie credit for I
I also see why it's sort of like ya know
even the sequences only have like
fragments in my mind that I remember
liking I don't nothing really like oh
yeah that moment you know yeah the main
association that movie left me with was
sort of that it took the things that
were successful about the first Thor the
tonal elements and just the different
you know elements of the world and
disjointed them instead of improving
upon them or you know streamlining them
in some ways so yeah ultimately it has
its moments but yeah I was not dazzled
and I was bummed because I love
Christopher Eccleston too what's number
21 for you John number 21 is another one
we debated and mostly it's here just
because I feel like in a lot of ways it
is just it doesn't quite fit in with the
rest of the movies and that is the
Incredible Hulk I mean there is some
really awesome
stuff about this especially like the
abomination fight the finale and all
that and again like with all these there
are elements to be appreciated but for
me anyway it's the one I think back on
and I'm like this just doesn't even feel
it feels like the one that didn't
coalesce with the rest of the series
yeah it's and have a similar thought I
see the thing is I put it above Thor the
dark world because I do think that a lot
of the chase sequences I really remember
those though it's been a year since I've
seen this movie but things have really
stuck with me and that fight with Hulk
and abomination there this movie at
least has sequences where I remember so
much of them because of how much they
left an impact on me whereas and I feel
like a lot of the in-between stuff is
when it's action is really gripping and
when it wants to be intense I find it
pretty intense yeah and even though even
when it wasn't the ideal Hulk movie I
think for a lot of people was like oh
we're getting closer to one and so you
know for that I got to give it a bit of
credit but what's next Gregory number 20
number 20 would have to be this is what
I could go get crap or whatever yeah
Gardens of the galaxy vol 2 we got crap
for this already when we first did our
review for not really loving this film I
liked Gardens you'll see on this list
the guardians of the galaxy vol 1 is a
movie that we we both really really
loved yeah and I'm sure there has to be
an element of the fact of how high the
bar was for Guardians 1 and how
Guardians 2 I know it's one of those
films where I appreciate so much of the
thought the ideas the concepts of just
the overall execution for me it didn't
quite work the comedy was very 50/50 for
me throughout a lot of this film I found
it to be a little bit lackluster for a
lot of it but I also get why people love
this movie that's why it's higher than
because honestly I probably like
guardians 2 less than the Incredible
Hulk if I'm being honest the thing
though is is I can I've wrote I can
really see why people love this movie so
on a logical technical scale I totally
get why people love this film and that's
why I put it higher than Incredible Hulk
yeah I mean for me in a lot of ways it
is my least favorite MCU movie but there
are
certain aspects of it that are some of
my favorites like I love all the yawn
like yawn you in the god but yeah I
think a theme of this bottom chunk of
our list is is kind of the mishandling
of characters in some way and again yeah
I feel like this ended up in this slot
because I do see it's it displeased me
because they made a specific choice that
I just didn't care for yeah and so by
going more funny and stripping away some
of the heavier elements of the
characters yeah I started to get kind of
annoyed by a lot of the elements on
screen so yeah yeah but number 19 what
is it John
Iron Man 2 and this is another movie
where like I I appreciate whiplash and
Justin Hammer quite a bit in fact I'd
love to see Justin Hammer come back to
the MCU yeah in some form and Robert
Downey is always great and you can
always rely on him to be amazing yeah he
is yeah but just overall I don't know
this this there are things about Iron
Man 3 I don't like but as a whole this
one just kind of feels bloated and it's
never as cool and engaging as you really
want it to be yeah oh man I completely
agree with you there yeah I feel like
the final moments especially when rody
and Iron Man are shooting all those
people down on the people yeah like that
moment school there's there's a lot of
cool stuff in it and I I don't think
it's as bad as people have made it out
to be over the years but yeah it is one
of those films really number 18
number 18 okay here here's where I can't
believe you guys will just put this uh
you know it's higher on the list than
guardians - that would be Captain Marvel
if you watch our especially or spoiler
talk you'll see that we we actually
really did like this movie a lot the
reason why it's actually on the lower
side here of the list is because the
least shining element of the movie
because there's a lot of great things in
it Nick Fury Ben Mendelsohn action
sequences a lot of the comedy really
worked goofs another thing is the the
thing about you most people don't go to
including us as like one of the main
highlights is Kat
to marvel herself or at least the thing
that has been most debated cuz I mean
even between it like no but if we loved
kept like if we loved brie Larson as
Captain Marvel would definitely be
higher on this for sure and again going
back to that theme of characters and I
want to say something really quick too I
think
brie Larson has had the hardest time
figuring out the character in terms of
being an actor for one of these movies
yeah because it's she's given limited
amount of homework to do and she's a
very she's one of those actresses that
seems like she needs a lot of homework
in order to get a role down properly
yeah it's like the same reason might
like Daniel day-lewis feels like he
needs to go to this crazy level of
commitment or to feel like he can do his
best and you know she shows up on set
for endgame doesn't even quite know who
she's playing or what her scene is and
that's her first day of filming
yeah backtrack here you know I feel like
she's had the hardest time so yeah and
that's something that I hope I hope in
the next Captain Marvel movie she does
get the benefit of like okay now you're
gonna be the one we tell all this let's
move moving on up we got an Avengers
movie but which one is it it's part n
its age of Ultron which again it has its
fun moments and in fact one of my
favorite MCU scenes is when they're all
trying to pick up Thor's hammer and it
does introduce like I think James Spader
is cool as all Tron but but ultimately
yeah the it the fun-ness of the movie
wore off for me you can feel the lack of
enthusiasm behind Joss Whedon in this
one you just feel it yeah yeah and I
feel like he's a guy who can make quips
happen for days so it's like it's easy
to have fun the first time around but
yeah is the more I think about it and
every time I've kind of revisited parts
of it it just feels overwrought by the
end of it I feel like the first Avengers
feels like Joss Whedon is bringing his
bringing himself and his passionate to
it yeah it's time that he's just doing
the job he's doing the checklist
required so while there are like some
funny moments while there are some great
action scenes in here the villain of
ultron is a bit of a letdown in turn and
in some of the mechanics of it we all
know the problems of ultron but we did
get vision yes we did
that is true we did get vision moving on
truly shine from there on this next one
is one we had to do beta actually a good
amount and its placement is kind of like
the averaging out of our feelings on
yeah definitely a preliminary movie for
Marvel and one that at least the first
half I think we can agree on would you
like to take it away yeah yeah Captain
America the First Avenger the first half
I I really do like this movie a lot and
that when it's Steve Rogers focused even
in weird bobble head looking CGI impose
things going on yeah even that I really
like those elements and after he becomes
Captain America we're never doing Steve
Roger moments I'm really much drawn to
there was the direction of it on it like
the way it was directed it was a bit of
a turn-off for me and I what I didn't
really care for the action moments in it
I felt the last half was rushed the Red
Skull stuff felt very generic it's like
I get what people say like one of those
you know 1940s you know I always I'm
like I understand I and if you love this
I get it if you like this to Joe
Johnson's word Johnston you like The
Rocketeer and then you watch yeah I
think correct me if I'm wrong but I
think also some of the things you're
saying may have had to do with the
production of the movie because I
actually don't disagree with some of
your criticisms even though I enjoyed
the movie more but I think he may have
been brought on kind of late after
somebody else had been left the project
or something well yeah but yeah I don't
know that's the movie that just I love
the charms and I love that by going
period with it they kind of opened
themselves up for further expansion in
genre yeah you know and moving on
therefore expansions in genre is another
kind of underrated first phase Marvel
movie I think it's very underrated oh
yeah and actually I want to say all
these films from here on out we just we
both agree we really like these yeah
yeah and this one comes from one of
Marvel's more like eccentric Direction
choices and that is a Kenneth Branagh's
Thor the first Thor and yes that's
guardians yeah yeah yeah and this one I
mean it has a great yeah blend of that
fantasy element that
Kenneth Branagh's great at bringing a
certain you know level of it I think he
was the right choice because he can have
it be this fantasy superhero movie but
also give some kind of credence to the
more classical elements of it it's
underrated I think especially because of
how well it handled bouncing back and
forth between you know a real commitment
to the fantasy land of Asgard and then
I'm watching out of life fantastical
character Thor you know live you know
stuck amongst us humans on earth because
that could have easily been some cheesy
90s movie where the fantasy stuff feels
totally cheesy yeah but this movie did a
great job at making both of it work
because when you're in the Asgardian
side of things you believe it and you
take it seriously and then you can have
fun with it when it's on earth I think
it's very underrated for that department
and even though Thor was serious yeah he
was great I planned the
fish-out-of-water stuff showing early on
like we want more of that kind of comedy
oh yeah one and when you know they they
everybody makes a big deal about
Ragnarok rebranding Thor but one of the
biggest things that stuck with me was
the humor of that first movie yeah and
yes definitely not a comedy like
Ragnarok but yeah yeah there's
definitely Cotters humor in it yeah and
plus I mean Asgard was a place that some
people were like I never thought I would
see them actually make it good as well
number 14 for us would have to be
ant-man yeah
Rudd the the reason why I actually
really enjoyed this movie a lot I think
it's a really really fun movie it's very
Marvel formula yeah and even though I
think all the actors do a great job at
it there's no character in here that I'm
necessarily in love with you know like I
like Paul Rudd I like Michael Douglas
I'll do a great like the only kicker I
love is my mic on yeah yeah he's not the
star of the movie and I love Michael
Pena in the film but yeah it's it's it's
a it does a solid job and it's funny and
I like the highest element to it and
they made this Colin I like when Marvel
can pull off these ideas that sound like
they could be so stupid you know I'm
sure I don't mean that as an offense to
convoy readers that sometimes you hear
these ideas and you think being brought
to the big screen the light work yeah
then they made it work the ant-man thing
is cool yeah and it was a nice splash
into the most overt comedy up until that
point and I'm surprised by how smooth
that played off considering the you know
I could write stages and all that the
movie had a deal with yeah for sure
moving on up we got another divisive
Marvel flick and that is uh you'll never
see me cutting Iron Man 3 which is
another one that I appreciate a lot of I
the only thing I don't enjoy about this
movie is like the third act when all the
Aldrich Killian stuff comes out and then
it becomes just kind of a an overlock
kind of disappointing twist superhero
movie ending yeah but I mean as much as
the twist with Ben Kingsley pissed
people off I liked that they made a bold
choice like that when I thought he was
the Mandarin I thought that stuff was
cool too and it was funny like do you
know that we saw that one together and
the first time we watched Iron Man 3 I
hated that twist hate it yeah
then as time went on I moved all of my
life visited the movie I was like you
know that seems really funny
like it's a really funny scene it's an
effective twist the thing of why the
effect wears down is because even on
just a film point the aldrich killian
stuff is nowhere near as effective of
everything we had built up for the
Mandarin no he's gotta be slightly
better or not just you know but I think
it's really funny and I think it's one
of the better the best Tony Stark
yeah mercy because yeah because it's so
Tony for most of it and barely he's
barely in the suit in the movie and so
he's literally yeah and so I say yeah I
like and I think it's a really
entertaining very Shane black kind of
movie and yes but it's really fun really
fun number 12 number 12 oh I think we
think this is very underrated yeah and I
think we might get some crap for the
placement but I ant-man in the wasp man
I don't care about I think the I think
this is a very underrated Marvel yeah
should have made more money yeah
definitely I mean I love the way that
this movie kind of the first one you
know that I liked a lot but the things
that Edgar Wright is great at are kind
of what I was hoping what I found to be
missing and this one I wasn't thinking
about that at all I thought they really
found their confident footing in how to
this ant-man world come to life they
made the shrinking and growing abilities
even more cleverly yeah integrated the
chemistry was better between Paul Rudd
and Evangeline Lilly I really I thought
she was better and I love the the turn
away from just having a villain into
even though the plot does kind of go
astray in some elements I like that the
stakes were more the antagonist and you
had a lot of different parties all
centering around one MacGuffin yeah you
know and I thought it and they enhance
the sci-fi world of the quantum really
actually I'd like this movie a lot yeah
I did I like yeah and I like every
character running an action sequences or
even really bizarre interrupting the
action scenes are very uh like the car
chase movie movie the car chase sequence
yeah I think it's great yeah so I think
it moved I think he just came in at the
wrong time and I'd had to come out
because the end game linkage but it just
it was so totally different and everyone
was wondering what's gonna happen this
is necessary to watch for infinity
warned you get these heavy stakes I just
think in a weird way it was a weird
timing for that movie to come out when
it did yeah but of all the Marvel flicks
like if I just wanted to hang out on an
afternoon and just like enjoy myself I
would probably reach for that one close
to that yeah it could have used the
better like villain sure but I still
liked it a lot number eleven on this
list or eleven we're cresting into the
kind of upper Goods I wanted to say this
this is another one for me where
emotionally I actually liked ant-man and
the wasp more than this movie like on an
emotional standpoint I do but this movie
I see especially I remember the first
time wide like it was there's a rewatch
where I didn't like it as much but the
first time I watched it I really liked
it and it also gave us in my opinion the
best interpretation of this character my
personal opinion John what is it it is
Spider Man homecoming spider-man
homecoming Tom Hollands first you know
feature-length film and yeah I mean it's
a great coming-of-age story it's a
really fun spider-man movie they get a
great balance of you know Peters
emotional life but also the quippy you
know web-slinging Spider Man he's also
got a great
relationship with Tony Stark in the
movie although that does kind of rub up
against one of the conflicts which is I
feel like that kind of and you brought
this to my attention actually the kind
of absence of the Uncle Ben presence and
kind of swapping that out for Tony Stark
well yeah I mean I know it didn't hit me
till this year just thinking about just
one I didn't want to steal your when
thinking about spider-man I did have
that feeling of what what is the thing
that's kind of missing for me about I
couldn't quite put my finger on it cuz
I'd love Tom Hollands portrayal I think
he is the best Peter Parker spider-man
we've gotten like even though is his
movie hasn't isn't my favorite
spider-man movie he's my favorite
spider-man but I did think that a
crucial element to Peter Parker is the
loss of Uncle Ben and we don't even need
to see though I don't think we needed
the loss of Uncle Ben and the origin
done again but if you think about it so
much of the weight and reasoning and
moral responsibility and his connection
of with Aunt May who's not his mom but
his aunt of what makes him so strongly
tightly connected is the loss of Uncle
Ben yeah and you know it's just that
that emotional reason being that
emotional weight is kind of what's
missing for me in that in homecoming I
suppose yeah of you know like even
though I really think it's a super fun
movie oh yeah and and Michael Keaton is
Walter's great that emotional wait I
could have used a little bit more of and
it's like I get the reasoning to not
focus on that I'm hoping it's kind of
explored a little bit in the next one as
opposed to just I want to you know
become an Avenger yeah Tony Stark yeah
yeah moving on right up the list then
this is one that that I loved a whole
lot on I don't know like Marvel movies
always grabbed me especially when they
take a pretty sharp left turn and I love
the mystical elements of this movie of
course we're talking about Doctor
Strange at number 10 and about the time
that this movie came out it just felt
like another breath of fresh air for
there you know
formula and they're you know the world
they were setting up and yeah to get
benedict cumberbatch you know further
you know continuing their reach out into
grabbing just all of the best actors
yeah now you know and yet is the
imagination of the movie and the like
the philosophy and the philosophical
element - yeah like it brings no
mysticism yeah yeah and I do think some
very inventive
you know inception like but more
fantastical actions I completely agree
with the complaint that Stephen strange
develops his powers so fast it becomes
like the master of all the mysticism so
quick it's kind of just you're like
where's all that where's all that stuff
they are you watch him struggle and
figure it out it yeah you know how much
dedication along really go I I do
completely agree with that but when I
let that side of things go like you know
a lot of times in movies does the the
logical problem of a situation is that -
does that interfere too much with your
emotional enjoyment of the movie
sometimes for me absolutely sometimes
not and for me that side of it and like
I can't let that go
yeah I know he's a big going to be
because there's enough things in there
that I really just get a kick out so
number nine number nine this would be a
controversial said to be honest I mean I
saw this movie three times and the
feeders and and I thought it got better
every single time and I do I like from
here on out
I love these beers we went from um
whatever about this one - I like this
one - I really like this one and now I
worthy I love somebody territory these
nine infinity war I like it's like the
fanservice movie that it is and the
amazing villain death anno cells and the
action scenes the epicness and the
collisions of stuff I really [ __ ]
love it
my one gripe about the movie
is that I think the middle portion of it
I disagree with some of the way this
movie is overall paced I know I get a
lot of distil greatly disagree with me
on that
this felt like the first part of it is
so fun so fast paced so exciting then it
really slows down and that part when it
slows down I thought really worked for
me the third time I watch this movie
yeah but I have to watch it three times
to sort of get there I don't know if it
had something to do with like
expectation and because we're gonna
shoot YouTube videos about it
I really gotta pay attention you know
instead of just sitting back and just
like letting all that [ __ ] go cuz I
think I wasn't able to get there until
the third time watching this movie and
yeah it's just that middle chunk kind of
dilute some of the pacing for me that's
really my one gripe about it out of that
I love that freakin ending is great and
it's a very exciting very exciting film
and it's a great villain so yeah yeah
yeah one it was a bold I don't know I
felt like it was a bold thing for Marvel
to not only achieve the greatest
crossover up until this point thus
further bringing their comic book world
to life but also leaving us with their
first truly heartbreaking somber note
and I mean they they were smart to be
like no no we're gonna follow this up
yeah yeah yeah but still to be left with
that and to be allowed to wait with that
you know did you know give me sort of in
a different kind of emotional attachment
to the MCU is sure yeah definitely like
it was a movie that every time I've seen
it or seen parts of it is has gotten
smoother because the first time I was
like whoa this is so much yeah but ya
know it's it's pretty terrific with the
road yeah I like weirdly I think endgame
greatly benefits because it's a three
hour movie and I think even infinity war
could have benefited even if in any war
would have worked as a longer film cuz
like somehow infinity war to me feels
longer yeah exactly and I've seen them
I've seen both of them three times and I
do agree like whenever end games and I'm
like yeah
and speaking of achievements then I
number
would have to be Avengers Assemble hmm
you you just can't be honestly I think
when I watch this at home
I missed the crowd I do yeah first time
you watch it in the theaters the one a
dystrophy the first time opening night
that was the most rewarding movie going
experience you awesomely ever have man
like they pulled it off they did it of
every single element of expectation
could this work this was out of any
movie to show like no we can make this
work it would it all rested on this one
movie and they they did it it is a very
fun move everything it needed to be for
me it's not a perfect film but for what
it needed to do it was perfect if that
makes sense
no I mean it achieves you know arguably
the impossible and it also brings job in
the best way made use of Joss Whedon's
distinct knack for working with
ensembles for infusing deconstructive
humor and yeah for just being able to
that shot where they're all on that
splash page where they're all on screen
together a battle of New York like is
one of the most iconic moments and I
just remember at the time like this is
truly these kinds of movies now I do
look forward to seeing like on opening
night with a crowd and that's not the
case for every movie but like I remember
both that energy and just knowing life
time Marvel fans who are friends of mine
who have been very picky up until this
point about the MCU films to see them
over Joel and B and even with Hulk like
with Mark Ruffalo to see like now that
they finally got it yeah like it was so
satisfying yeah like that emotional
impact has always stayed with me so
absolutely yeah
number seven this is a very logically
chosen one because I feel like this
movie is most likely number one two
three
III feel actually I told my girlfriend
Olivia about where this was and boy was
she mad because this is where this is
her second favorite one
and that's Captain America Winter
Soldier I it's pretty great
it's a it's a great great the thing is
it's a great film great it's a great
espionage thriller the action is
bone-crunching
I love where it took the story I thought
this was the defining a more of this is
what I really grew to really love Steve
Rogers yeah as a character because he
actually had some like in in terms of
actual portrayal not just the you know
oh yeah yeah yeah like because even by
the end of Captain America first made
you're like okay still the light-hearted
good guy yeah this when you put them in
darker territory and I really liked it
harsher political climate yeah and you
know introduction of Falcon and
everything it's the the thing is you
know the it's such a serious movie that
I can't always get into it because
having the mood yeah you got to be in
the mood I'm not always like on the edge
of my seat with that movie yeah because
it's so serious it's like from the Russo
brothers and there's real like a no copy
like there's humor that will come into
play at times with Falcon and Captain
America but most of the movie is a very
serious yeah and I can't just always put
it on because of that fact you know
yeah I feels yeah yeah I could have used
a little more fun I guess and to be one
that you would want to throw on any old
time yeah yeah like I don't my I don't
think though I love the seriousness of
it when I'm in the mood for it but yeah
but it's not good at rant it's not gonna
transition my mood if I'm already not in
the mood to watch it yeah you know if I
was with a larger film fan and they were
just like show me a great Marvel movie
III might put that in my stat potentials
you know like before some of the other
ones definitely moving on up we are at
number six we're almost to the top five
and this is another they're all
significant by this point but um this is
the one that started it all Thor the
dark like Iron Man the first Iron Man
like it's x-men x-men yeah it's the it's
the old wasn't Dolph Lundgren or
something
ya know is he who is Nick Fury
I don't know yeah Iron Man Iron Man this
was grace gathered right we saw this
together I got interviewed for the reals
oh yeah for even did YouTube
surprisingly accurate I remember you
said that - he was surprisingly accurate
I thought
Iron Man iced I've probably seen this
one more than any of MCU movie and the
reason why is because I used to donate
plasma and if it's don't be on that
chair for an hour in the waiting room
for an hour just watch
obviously did so many times but it
really is a great film and you know
what's funny it is the best at just
being a standalone it's like yeah they
have shield in there but it's not exact
sin with the plot yeah and seems more
like a thing to set up for a sequel as
opposed to set up for a university
that's what they're doing you know they
do have that post credit scene of course
but I think this is just a great film
this is a wonderful film that is you
know it's well it's probably the most
political movie - they're only getting
in and the crisis that Tony has is all
about who he's supplying weapons to and
and you know the only problem with the
movie is the whole you know thing that
became a trope for Marvel what is the
idea that Jeff Bridges hops to the Iron
Monger suit and then you know is your
master powerful version and becomes like
the master of it yeah yeah whereas Tony
had to you know spend at the while like
figure out how this all works and and
jeopardy just figures out right away but
before that I think Jeff Bridges is
great he's a wonderful Obadiah and and
then even I remember watching that in
the theaters and when he says I would
scraps and then the scientist goes well
I'm not Tony Stark
everyone laughed and clapped and this is
the first movie but but we've already
gotten such a great point by that moment
like with
everything with Tony Stark that by the
time they say that I didn't read any
Iron Man comics so by the time they said
that I was even clapping cuz I was like
yeah that's introduces its lead
characters so flawlessly and it has so
many great moments that like when you
think back on again great MCU images a
lot of Iron Man moments come to mind a
lot of the emotional beats come to mind
and a lot of you know it long enduring
characters man yeah like you know and
yeah Jon Favreau really take a turn in
his career to you know Tony and pepper
my every I think it's a wonderful
wonderful movie
yeah and Terrence Howard man I don't
know what the word is on this but I did
prefer Terrence Howard as roadie yeah I
thought their chemistry was perfect
mm-hmm and that and I don't really feel
for the chemistry between Don Cheadle
and Robert Downey because I think Don
Cheadle is actually an amazing accurate
don't really feel for the chemistry that
he has a Robert Downey jr. where I
really feel like Terrence Howard Robert
Downey are friends what's number five
John you take this one number five is a
recent issue one and it's the Ragnarok
man it gave us Jeff Goldblum in the MCU
it gave us the most humor we've ever had
in the MCU it's it's just it's basically
just a Tyco whitey the joint with Thor
elements adorned upon it but it is so
much fun and it really was it is a shot
in the arm that not everybody loved I
know but a lot of people loved and it's
just such a confident I feel like I feel
like most people loved I think I think
that people who don't like it just had a
pretty strong voice but I think most
people love this yeah yeah and it's just
it's got a very confident very colorful
and very whimsical element to it that
really just helps further expand both
the fantastical and cosmic elements and
I don't know man and also I mean the
Thor Hulk relationship is one that a lot
of people really love and that has you
know since grown past that and endgame
and not just Hulk in it so and Bruce
Banner and Bruce yeah yeah Valkyrie the
villain of hella
you know and I also think this movie
doesn't get enough credit for the way
it's shot like sure is it primarily a
comedy yeah but there are some beautiful
imagery yes you know it's more than just
taiko YTD doing his you know improvise
it is it is genuinely a wonderfully shot
film with some great action in it as
well it is I think a very very very
entertaining film and one that really
sticks with you it I think it's one that
really really yeah a great theme beyond
all the humor and stuff like that about
Asgard at the end about how you know
it's not about the chunk of land that
you live on necessarily it is the
community that you have with you it is
the people Asgard as a people you know
well I can't think of a standalone film
that introduces so many new characters
who are not major players I think
there's an argument to be made for
something like black panther perhaps but
thor ragnarok not only is everyone
hailing this ree you know revamp of
chris hemsworth portrayal of thor yeah
and you know and of course you know the
brother relationship loki but everyone's
talking about what they did with the
hulk and Bruce Banner yes a big player
but also Valkyrie I agree Grandmaster
horde you know these characters you're
like who are these guys yeah great
they're back in and now we're excited
when they're there yeah you know these
are I think it deserves the credit it
received
oh yeah number four would have to be
Captain America Civil War this movie III
I do not like the criticism of any MCU
film at all of yeah I don't like the
criticism of you know when someone says
the issue with it is you have to see the
other ones in order to appreciate the
disorder to really look like over break
it higher but the problem is you have to
see the other one like what that's kind
of what makes the MCU specials because
they're the one of the very few well
yeah it's the it's the the franchise
that has that unique touch to it because
of the connective tissue all the films
have
you know that I've always viewed this as
the the greatest most expensive TV show
we've ever had to pay to watch you know
like one of those things because I that
that criticism does bother me because
it's kind of the point of what the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is that's the
point whereas other franchises seem to
try to emulate it for a reason because
that's not organic with a lot of the
other franchises where this one that was
the initial inception for what they
wanted to do and civil war I think does
a great job at yes essentially an
Avengers movie in a lot of ways but with
Tony and cap as the central focus of the
film and I love the superhero debate
they decide to have in it the conflict
you don't really know like yeah I guess
I get where both of them are coming from
in the movie and you know some people
really do side with Iron Man in that
film and some people really do side with
Captain America in the movie as well I
think that it's a wonderful film with
amazing action sequences and the right
amount of humor it's an overall a
serious film but there's a pretty good
amount of humor
by the time you get to Spider Man Ant
Man Lang and decide to have the airport
battle those are just so like how can
you forget that like Bucky grabbing the
bike when they were chasing under the
freeway or the introduction of
spider-man there's so man third eye I
think this is an epic film and even
though onry watches I feel like the
airport battle is kind of
inconsequential and we're all necessary
to the movie it's still a great fight
you know yeah yeah well and that's a
movie for myself I often draw a
distinction between movies and films you
know for certain things just as kind of
a semantic thing and sometimes I feel
like Marvel makes Marvel movies and
sometimes they make Marvel films and
this one up until that point was one
that struck me as like the best
synthesis of both yes it's got all those
soaring heights that like a blockbuster
spectacle has that a lot of the all of
the Marvel movies have but also has some
weight and some emotional resonance of
an actual like you know oh I'm watching
like kind of a serious film it's
bothering to have this debate about the
ethics of heroism and stuff like that
and it's funny
you know cuz we got multiple movies
around that time trying to talk about
that idea and I thought they did a
pretty decently successful job at least
of using those issues to fuel the thrust
of the movies so yeah this one
definitely left an impression and at
least at the point that I saw it was
definitely from the first viewing one of
my favorites yeah number three would
have to be oscar-winning movie segwaying
right out of Civil War
yeah Black Panther Panther Black Panther
kill mongers my favorite villain I who
would win in a fight between San Jose
kill your obviously bad like I don't
know shoot yeah yeah Black Widow was
prepping for that's not in the endgame
movie
I think kill monger is the best
character portrayed villain ever from
the MCU
I love fan oohs sure I really do think
he's a wonderful villain infinity war
and he is a much bigger threat but kill
monger I love how personal it was with
him to the point we were like you know
with Thanos you're kind of like I get it
what he's doing I don't agree
kill monger I go I really get where this
guy's because the movie is rooted in
some real-life circumstances in real
life culture you know you get the extra
benefit of having a very easy to access
you know emotional drive for his
character yeah and so even if you don't
necessarily agree with his master plan
you do understand his philosophy a whole
lot and it's very lived in in that
regard yeah yeah I think it's really
intense mm-hmm I it's the honestly out
of all these movies it was probably the
first MCU movie that had moments that
brought me to tears
yeah and it's it's an epic and I think
that because of how hyped it was
crossing a billion and everything like
all the all the recognition of God of
course then started opening the door to
a lot of people hating on this seems
overhyped it's not as great as people
make it out to be some saying it's even
the one of the worst ones of the MCU it
has elements of superhero movie to it I
mean I don't honestly love like the the
subway fight at the end you know the
rail train fight yeah but overall I mean
they even bring in more of the genre
splicing with the sort of spy movie
heist stuff towards the top and then
again all those cultural things and they
do bother to have a sort of global
socio-political at least subtext touched
upon in the movie and I can't think of
any wasted actors no in it whereas a lot
of these you know it's like you got like
the guard is a galaxy one which has
Glenn Close in it whereas in this movie
you can have a really small role for
like Danai gurira or Forest Whitaker do
ya Clark do Winston Duke oh I'm sorry
yeah Clark Duke you would be great
there's no glasses
Martin Freeman even the white guys are
gray I think it's a wonderful film yeah
it's never been like number three on my
list and it's never swayed from there I
love the joy that this movie sparked to
because the amount of just people out
there who were touched by I mean you
know I'm sure some people are gonna roll
their eyes at me but like you know so
many people to feel represented by that
movie's awesome Mexican people who like
thank God we're here you know I mean
there hopefully will be more doors
flying open for more and more cultural
acceptance but that was just a really
wonderful thing to see the people like
this was one I don't love social media
especially surrounding you know certain
geek culture topics but this was one
where it was just really nice to see how
much joy it brought many people so yeah
I agree one of my favorite memories is
watching a family take a photo at the
theater and wanting to remember that
night on that giant pose yeah I'll never
forget that number two even though I had
a little car into the galaxy yeah
probably one eye there there are things
you can nitpick in all these moves this
is this is just this is personal
preference this is just my kind
movie yeah honestly like I love sci-fi
sci-fi was one of my favorite genres one
of those underrated genres like even
though the sci-fi could be a big
blockbuster juggernaut and it's like I
think prestige wise its kind of
overlooked and guardians of the galaxy
ensemble piece they're all great they
had an ale all the guardians and they
got them all day how do you know and
they're all introduced the
world-building the humor the music the
spectacle
I mean sure Ronan the accuser is not a
wonderful villain but you know I don't
really care about that because
everything else really [ __ ] excels I
mean Ronan has to you know show up and
beat up Drax it's fine it's build the
stakes you know I believe they hated him
and I believe they like I don't even
know when we check it when them he's not
great the makeup on him is cool but you
know I thought he was I thought the way
the characters responded to the villain
was wonderful maybe the villain himself
wasn't great either way it's a super fun
movie oh yeah and I love the the emotion
in it that's so much heart it's a it's a
beautiful film to me and very inventive
very unique oh yeah well this is one
that I appreciated too at the time
because it was up until that point one
of the most like whoa they're really
expanding their horizons with this you
know going full space opera now which
was just a gratifying thing as a person
who personally just likes when people
mix in more and more elements and
diversify and stuff like that and it was
also really satisfying because up until
that point I had been a fan of James
Gunn and I don't always love his tone of
voice but in that movie I feel like he
got a great balance of some of the most
humor up until that point we'd had for
Marvel also you know some actual sci-fi
stuff some actual you know character
beats that were resonant and then really
endeared me to the group and it really
felt like a Marvel movie that was very
much helmed by its director like I was
like wow they really let him make a
James Gunn movie out of this that's a
big point that's a great point because
out of all the MCU movies that style is
so definitive that the thought of when
James Gunn was temporarily fired you're
like no one's gonna want to touch this
no one's gonna touch this you know like
even though I you know I think
yeah what Aiko YTD did for Ragnarok was
amazing you know a lot of people thought
that because of guardians it gave thor
ragnarok the ability to do that
so guardians out of all them have such a
definitive style that you just wouldn't
want to get a different director
attached to it
yeah and that's seeing something pretty
special about a film about a franchise
it realized so much on connectivity that
you can swap out directors expanded the
imagination yeah it was it was one of
those checkpoints of being dazzled again
yeah cuz it's like you know each phase
has a couple points that will actually
really wow me beyond what I'm kind of
used to you know and that was definitely
one of them well number one you guessed
it you've heard us say it but obviously
yeah you've heard me say this a billion
times I've seen this three times
officially go watch an IMAX it's amazing
it is a vendor's endgame it's a game
this is personally the for the perfect
representation of the MCU it rewards the
the fans it knows how to do fan service
and of in a way that isn't just fans
service it's not the opening shot of age
of Ultron you know feels like a fan
appreciation and within a fan service
and I think out of any MCU movie it
earns like I think when they're
time-traveling are there like fanservice
shots sure but for the most part it's
very story based they all for the most
part makes sense it's not just
fanservice moments you know like hey
let's look back at the time-travel
moments and go they remember that moment
it's not that it those moments added
more intensity to the story things go
wrong it's it's really great I love the
build up to it but my point is the build
up to the finale where you start getting
like the most you can think of it is
earned it I be you can't there's no
other movies beyond the MCU but
definitely within the MCU that have
fanservice stuff or you're like oh gosh
just fanservice you know that's not
really necessary but when you get that
[ __ ] in the finale
it is so earned the action is so earned
it
any action before that hey no and
there's it's so harrowing and a hard
leading up to it that when you started
getting it it still feels even though
like oh the shot of all the women you
know giant giant ant-man you know
putting a hulk and and rocket in his
hand the whole crowd of people
Captain America are saying Avengers
Assemble it really Munir Stormbreaker
and you know a hammer and one like so
much of those things they still feel
within story somehow not just fanservice
yeah so I I feel just even more out into
the comic book realm you know like in it
I feel like it feels like a true epic
mm-hmm you know you know it really does
it has all that scope and all that scale
and you know like it's all up there on
the screen you know I mean you
understand why these movies take so much
to produce and yeah this movie I think
yeah it really does just encapsulate the
MCU partly too because the way it uses
previous movies and even improves upon
previous movies and ties up a little
halt like it it does even in its form in
a way that doesn't feel cheesy make you
appreciate all the time spent you know
in all the different places that we've
been over time and yeah it was one movie
it's like infinity war already had to
achieve the impossible by living up to
so much hype and then this movie had to
do that again and one thing that really
struck me is the first time I saw it I
realized there was a moment where I mean
there were times early on when they made
choices where I was like oh cool I'm
gonna get a movie that's as interesting
as I'm hoping it will be but I realized
at a certain point I forgot about
whatever expectations and I was just
locked into the movie and completely
wrapped and just onboard for the
emotional catharsis of the adventure
it's a perfectly paced
and it's so character driven yeah it
doesn't feel like three hours like it's
so care like everyone is dealing with
grief in their own ways and we did that
five years later jump it is dealing I
had a long time with a different patron
ideally Chamberlain about this where it
is a study of like how would these guys
be grieving in this moment and you know
like Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner Hulk
he's the one who learns to find the
and acceptance in this grieving stage
and get into the gamma-ray place for
over a year and figure this out
Thor becomes an alcoholic and gains a
bunch of weight tony has trying to move
forward you know cap is trying to like
do support like it's it's so wonderfully
character-driven hawkeye of course it's
so wonderfully character-driven and you
know i feel like a lot of the other
movies that are even character driven
are still trying to balance it out with
like whoa you know it structurally was
probably an action scene here yeah think
about those things here you're trying
increase the stakes this one didn't care
about that I feels unencumbered by the
needs of a comic book blockbuster and it
feels completely beholden to the needs
of its own story yeah you know which is
how it ought to be written wife spoiler
talk was an hour in 20 minutes and it
could have been longer honestly well the
other thing too is is we talk about
subversion all the time but one thing
that's also great is like I remember you
brought this up with the way everybody
comes back it's like the movie has you
so into it that you don't even at least
for both of us I wasn't even thinking
about where everybody else yeah and
that's the big thing that infinity war
leaves you with you most of us who
follow the movie news all day sit there
and go well they're all coming back yeah
you know and that didn't hamper this
movie at all for me it was like amazing
that they were able to just completely
brush past that you know and I've never
been so emotionally swept up by any of
the MCU films as much as like this I
would I've never actually hailed any of
the MCU movies as one of my favorite
movies endgame is probably just one of
my favorite movies because of the what
it managed to pull off like this go and
it was cool watching it a third time
when you're not with it was obvious that
even though the theater was primarily
full most those people had already seen
the movie before so wasn't a crowd of a
bunch of you know cheering and oh my god
I can't believe I'm seeing this there
was literally like one guy there was
like oh wow
I look after the Thanos's heck of a
fighter he goes oh but you know when you
watch it with a crowd it's different and
it can be easy to just feel the crowd
and then you go oh now that I watched it
without a crowd it's really not as great
this movie watching it with it just a
team with a tame crowd where it's not
like [ __ ] crazy bananas you're I was
like I'm still crying yeah now you have
to go towards the end of its theatrical
run when there's like three people so
watch it alone on your phone yeah movie
is awesome it's some special and again
you know it's one of several moments
that Marvel has really been able with
their Cinematic Universe to bring you
just feel the community even if you're
only in the theater full of a few people
you just feel how many people are
communing over this and that you know
bringing people together that way and
making people celebrate that way is you
know as many ways as there are to be
cynical about that I always feel that in
my soul jelly and I'm always really
happy when that happens it's funny how
the elements of it there are elements in
here that are divisive Captain America
time travel what happened
those were exactly and you know a lot
there's a pretty big divide on the
handling of black widows death beyond
that it blows my mind that they've
managed to wrap up so many things and
for the most part and satisfy people and
things you weren't even expecting them
to go rally
yeah I boggles my mind how damn they did
it yeah yeah I thought I'd have all them
that this would have the hardest time
and probably be I thought this would be
the most divisive yeah Avengers movie
but man if they do it what still like
movies like this make me tense yeah like
just the prospect of
like so many ways this could go wrong
this has to be amazing like you reach a
point where you have to be great
otherwise you're gonna have a friends
you have to be great or else you're
terrible like it's just a thing it is
the way our culture is yeah anyway guys
do you stick around this long do you
like season eight of game what how would
you rank it yeah how would you rank it
but you're calling us [ __ ] just list
your own Rayo Andrew thanks so much for
requesting this buddy guys go check out
his youtube channel those movie or
review is talks a lot about wrestling
and sign this petition to become the new
Wolverine did you really make one if not
oh no I know I was like damn I wish you
would have well now I am sincere let's
start one somebody start one he is two
foot five I know do is grow is you know
if big old sideburns
don't tease your hair up on the sides
all right guys you can subscribe for the
reject nation click that notification
about will see you guys soon
[Music]